here's where we begin you get this um
this equation that you need to satisfy
that's your polynomial
and then they introduce this idea that
alpha is this complex root
of this equation so alpha is not real
okay so we know that um or at least it's
not
solely real it's got a real part
imaginary part which comes in later on
okay and then it says if that's what
alpha is it's a solution to this
then let theta equal and then there's
these weird like seemingly
random i think it's like alpha alpha
uh squared and alpha four
and then phi which is these
other powers of alpha and you're like
what on earth is that about
okay so then the next part says
show that um and they give you this
result so
this is what we're required to prove
this is where we're headed
we want to get some relationships
between these two whatever they are
okay so i think it was that the sum
is negative one and the product is
two is that right yeah cool all right
so what do you do when you even begin
right so we're gonna go back to
like let's think about this for a second
right see this and this
line they're just defined okay so they
don't really give you any
interesting or valuable information um
but these two
these are kind of like facts right it's
like look i can tell you something about
alpha it has
these particular qualities it's it's a
solution of this polynomial
and this polynomial um also is a look
that's a fact this is known and you can
then conclude things from it okay
so this is kind of the important part
here that we're going to build off
these are the facts right there's
nothing you can't build anything off
these because these are just labels okay
so we're going to get to these but when
you think about like a question gives
you all these different things
when they say let right this is kind of
arbitrary they could have been equal to
different things
right so you should start from um
yeah these aren't they're not gonna give
you a helpful starting point you'll just
go round and round in circles
because these aren't giving you any
information okay
um it'd be a little bit like when you
get a circle geometry question
right something like this and you're
like okay um
here's an angle i'm going to call that
alpha okay now this doesn't give you
much useful information at all like i
can't draw any conclusions from it but
if i told you
if i told you all of a sudden for
instance that you know
um um this is badly drawn but suppose i
said look that goes through the center
and then i gave you like a sign it's
like pine on six or something like that
you're like oh this is a fact i can i
can deduce things from this
you can't deduce anything from that
because it's just a it's just a label
you could have called it that or that or
anything
right which is the same thing here so
we're going to bring this into play
later
right but it's not a good starting point
so therefore here's where i'm going to
begin
um z to the power of seven equals one
now that's good that tells you that this
is going to have something to do with
the fact that
remember how alpha is a um it's a it's
the smallest argument
right so therefore if i were to draw a
diagram right
um so you draw yourself a little diagram
here
so this means that if i take alpha
right which should satisfy this equation
right if i
raise it to the power of seven i should
end back at
one there's one there okay so in other
words
if i because because multiplication by a
complex number is rotation
yes so that's why your diagram looks
something like this uh i can't remember
something you know like that like that
you know yeah that's exactly right right
so that means that
if i go around seven times okay
that's going to bring me back to one
okay which tells you that the
the size of one of these angles being
that the whole revolution is two pi
right then the size of one of these
angles and it's the smallest one
should be two pi on seven yeah okay so
so that's useful and we'll come back to
that you can have a look at the later
parts of the question
you can see that 2.74.7 it's clearly
related somehow
okay but the question is the question is
how right
okay so you note that you're like okay
i'll i'll get to that one later
i need to do something which will bring
in all these extra powers of alpha
right so clearly you notice like it goes
alpha to parallel one
two three four five six and then it
stops
right so that gives you a clue that okay
this
these powers they must have something to
do with this power
right because they stop at seven if as
it were
okay like it doesn't go it doesn't stop
at say
three and doesn't stop at ten it stops
just shy of seven so what do they have
to do with each other all right
so this is a bit rabid out of a hat this
part but i'm trying to show you why
there are clues that lead you to this
point
i'm going to rewrite our polynomial like
this
same thing right but the reason this is
useful is i can factorize it
now this is not a common kind of thing
to factorize you don't see this kind of
thing very often right
what you do see um results that you do
know
are say difference of squares right so
the difference of squares we know how to
factorize
z minus one z plus one okay
because i did it do cubes right we did
learn like in year
in year 9 10 you learn the sum and
difference of cubes okay
so we were supposed to okay um
so so therefore sorry because you came
here in stage six anyhow um
we can factorize this so there's a
there's a
mnemonic for this by the way i don't
know if you've ever learned it this is a
very specific case the general case
looks like this
here's the difference of cubes and here
is the sum
of cubes okay so the way that you do it
is
um they both have the same structure so
this is how you can remember it right
so you're going to get a b a squared a b
b squared right and it's going to be the
same for each one the trick is just to
remember
where the sides go so the mnemonic that
you use to remember is so
oh really okay so the signs work like
this
there are three sides right one two
three you fill them in by saying the
first one's the same
the next one's the opposite and the last
one is always positive no matter what
okay so look at this minus same opposite
always positive and the same thing here
so
same opposite always positive
okay so that's how i remember that
because it's quite finished
to um to to get all the signs right
i go back and i'm like yeah you can
expand it out obviously it's like
okay good yes i'm sure right um so
obviously that works but the time
consuming so in a pinch this will work
for you
now we've got a difference here so i'm
just going to get rid of this guy
all right and you'll also notice that my
b
is one which is kind of neat right so
here
i should have um this will be z minus
one
yeah right now what happens in here
i'll have a squared right so that's
gonna be
z squared plus a b which is
z times one which is just z plus b
squared which is
one squared oops plus one okay there you
go
right now this is interesting now i can
get rid of this
um clearly there's a pattern happening
here isn't there right
and you can almost guess what would
happen if you would have z to the four
minus one you'll still be able to take
out that
z minus one right just following the
pattern what would you
guess what would you expect to get from
this
yeah z cubed and then there will be a z
squared and then there will be a z and
then there'll be a one and again
you can test it out by expanding but you
can kind of see how it's going to work
watch this right you get this z
and that z cubed and they'll become a z
to the power of four
tick right now then when you get when
you pair up
when you pair up this guy with this guy
you'll get a z cubed
and a z squared and a z right but then
you're gonna subtract
all of those and you'll be left with a
minus
one hanging at the end so you can see
that i can generalize this
i can generalize it as far as i like
okay and now you can see where this is
coming from okay
so i'm going to say this is true
okay but but
alpha is a solution of this right well
alpha satisfies this equation that's
what it means
that alpha
is one of the roots okay so it makes
that work so that means this is true
okay and now i'm going to pull out this
um this factorizing trick right
so if i factorize i should get this
alpha minus one and because this pair is
seven
i'm gonna start with one less right
ta-dah okay
so this will be alpha six alpha five
alpha four all the way
down the ladder and that should be zero
okay so this is good um now
you have a look at what you're what
we're getting towards right so this
theta plus phi okay that's
alpha plus alpha squared alpha cubed
that's that's
this thing here almost
that's right huh that's suspicious right
but we're not there yet are we we've got
this guy hanging around
so how do i get rid of this right okay
so alpha since i know it's complex
it can't be one right so i can say
but but alpha can't equal one
right as um as it's not real
okay so if this can't be zero if this
can't be zero then this has to be zero
so that's alpha six alpha five so this
is the first part
of part one that we needed to prove um
that's equal to zero yeah
so then we'll keep that guy over we'll
replace these by the theta and the phi
which is just the labels
um that's equal to negative one
okay so that's good
right so we've used this this quaint
factorizing thing
um you can't do the same for um
not quite though it can be done if you
think about it um
you can factorize but it's not as neat
so and there's another there's another
different result for it with alternating
science yeah
so but we don't have to worry about that
in this case okay
now where does this go um okay
so we did we sort of went from here
and then we went down okay we have this
handy result when you look at this
right um theta
times phi we know what theta is and we
know what phi
is so i can actually multiply these out
and i should get something that relates
to what i already know
okay so i'm gonna give that a go and see
what happens so i'm just gonna do
um what do i write theta times
phi okay now this looks like it will be
awkward
and really long but it's actually not so
bad because of how structured
the thing is that we're trying to the
things are that we're trying to multiply
okay
so i've got here alpha alpha squared
alpha to the four
alpha cubed alpha 5 alpha 6.
okay now i've got triples so that i
don't overwhelm myself
i'm going to do this in three lines so
that i know i don't miss a term or
anything like that
okay so i'll do alpha by all of these
first so it just raises all those powers
by one
so i should get this um
seven yeah okay so there's the first
triplet then i'll do the next triplet
which raises them all by
two so that should be five seven
and eight and then the last triplet so
so far so
good um seven nine and ten
okay now apparently this all boils down
to two so the answer is how do i get 2
out of that
well you can see a few handy things here
right for instance everywhere you see an
alpha to the power of 7
i know what alpha the power of 7 is
because it satisfies
this equation so all of those guys are
one so i'm just going to replace those
just quickly now
with another color so i've got
this will just save me rewriting the
whole thing all over again
so i've got a one here one here one here
that's kind of nice right
now what do i have left i've got an
alpha four
five and six which is kind of it's kind
of part of this right
but then you have these higher powers of
alpha and you're like what do i do with
those
um now the thing is i can do the same
thing with those
that i did with these i can take out a
factor of alpha to the power of seven
because it's just
one okay so this is worth a new line um
that's one two three so i'll just i'll
just write that down
and then i've got my alpha four alpha
five alpha to the 6.
now what's left is what's left is these
guys
so i'll take out a factor of alpha 7
from all of them
so plus alpha the power of 7 outside of
um
alpha alpha squared alpha cubed
alpha squared alpha cubed which is
exactly the terms i'm missing over here
isn't it
so now i can just replace this alpha 7
with a one
okay so now what am i left with um
it looks to me like i'm left with uh
this line see see this this
here that's um if i put them all
together
i should get theta plus five so that's
three plus negative one which is two as
required
okay
isn't it so easy when you see the
solution
when you're trying to obviously i've
taken a straight line haven't i
so i knew exactly where i was trying to
head which is why i can get there so
quickly
um but hopefully you can see like the
clues that i used
for example how did i how did i know to
pull
to pull this rabbit out of a hat right
it's like well
i knew i had to get something involving
this right
out of this like where does it come from
it must be factorized
and once you get this result this one
kind of falls out
okay